- Hi everyone.
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy,
and I just wanted to welcome you
to this course on internet safety.
Now, you might be saying,
"Why should I look at this course?
The internet seems like
this fun and fabulous place
where I can interact with folks
and get information and do
all of these great things,"
but you also need to realize
that the internet can
be a dangerous place.
There are people who are
going to want to get access
to your personally
identifiable information,
the things that would allow folks to say,
take a credit card in your
name, or pretend to be you,
or steal money from you.
So you wanna figure out,
how do you protect that?
And we'll have a lot more
content on what exactly PII,
or personally identifiable information is.
As you know on the internet,
you have many accounts.
It could be an account for a site
that allows you to play video games,
but it could be your banking account.
It could be where you send
emails from, your social media.
There are folks out there that would love
to have access to those accounts.
They might be able to directly
do things on those accounts.
It could be as little as embarrass you
by taking advantage of
your social media account,
or it could be stealing money from you
if it's your bank account, or if you have
the same password in
multiple places, well,
they might be able to use that
from one place to another.
So beware of everything on the internet.
You have a lot of
information about yourself
that could be valuable to others.
And you're also going learn
that some of those folks
are going try to trick you.
You're gonna learn about
things like phishing attacks,
where they're gonna try to
pretend to be someone else
and make you feel really
urgent about doing something
and giving information, once again,
that you do not want these folks to have.
So take a look at this course.
It's going to be very,
very important to you.
Hopefully none of this
stuff ever happens to you
but if it does, you'll
know what to do about it,
but even more importantly,
you're going to know how to prevent it.
So hopefully you enjoy this course.